the crazy old bat was there again
slumped on the bench out
my courtroom she looked more like a
mountain of rags than a person she must
have been wearing for coats and three
hats and God the smell and there was her
ever-present wire shopping cart stuffed
with God knows what no matter how I
tried to slip by her into my courtroom
somehow even though she looked
unconscious on the bench she was
watching her head would suddenly swivel
in my direction and there was a crazed
glazed intensity to her eyes buried deep
within a face of weathered wrinkles and
out from under all those clothes she
would pull that giant sheaf of ragged
papers and she hold it up and shakes it
at me as though it were a sword and she
croaks my case my case I was a tough
judge that's why they elected me I
didn't care who you were or what your
Excuse was if you do the crime you do
the time I've stared down criminals who
could easily have rip my arms off and
would have enjoyed doing it some people
said I should show mercy and try to
understand people and their problems but
justice only works if it's consistent
and brutal but this crazy old bag I
would cross through the courthouse
basement and come up the back stairs
just to get away from her but still
somehow I knew she'd find me years ago I
once tried listening to her I called her
before the bench and asked her what her
problem was the case was some ancient
grievance against a no-good son in law
who sold the house and took the money it
had been through every Court in the
county and she been turned away every
time she babbled on at the top of her
voice shaking one paper from another
from that overflowing folder it sort of
made sense for the first half hour but
then had wandered off into Duluth
and shouting I really do fear no one not
God not any person but this crazy old
woman she scared me when I finally
granted her judgment I told people is
because she had warned me down day after
day coming to the courthouse and I was
just trying to clean things up but it's
not the truth i granted her judgment
because she embarrassed me into it it
was take your daughter to work day one
year and my beloved Sarah just 12 was
coming with me to the courthouse and to
tell the truth I really wanted her to be
impressed but what a great man i was and
i think i really am but outside the
courtroom as i was pointing out my
portrait along the hallway with the
other distinguished judges there she was
the crazy lady bearing down on us
leaning on her wire shopping cart a
giant ugly smelly lump of clothes waving
that folders of papers like it was on
fire my case my case he's taken
everything from me help me sarod folded
herself into my judicial roads in fear
and I put up the hand and push past the
old woman Sarah was duly impressed by
the ceremony of the court and the
dignity of her father's work that day
but she seized on the old woman and
wouldn't let it go with the absolute
justice of a 12 year old what did she
want daddy why can't you help her aren't
you a judge aren't you supposed to help
and I said no Sarah you know it's very
complicated and even I can't just make
up the law to be nice to people but
daddy it says right there on the wall of
your courtroom justice for all what
about the old lady it went on for two
weeks and finally it was my daughter
that'd be me not the old woman I saw
myself through a child's eyes which had
no understanding of contingencies and
complications and after all my years as
a judge it was my child who shamed me
into giving justice I've taken a few
liberties with the parable as you
noticed but I think it's worth it to
bring it a little closer to home because
this is the parable seemed so simple the
introduction says don't lose heart keep
praying there's a lot more going on here
than just that it's not just about pray
really hard and you'll get what you want
because though we were taught that in
Sunday school we've lived through other
moments in our lives when we really did
pray hard or someone we loved really
didn't pray hard and it didn't happen
this story is probably something Jesus
picked up off the street a rumor about a
woman who'd overcome this bad judge but
he takes it and he turns it on its head
as he always does just listen to how
weird it is what's the comparison he's
comparing God to this unjust judge
something weird about that he's saying
God is just like this corrupt judge who
won't give anyone justice but he's a
little bit nicer and you'll still have
to pray a whole bunch to overcome God's
reluctance to give you justice doesn't
sound like the God Jesus has been
talking about it all
or you could just say this parable is
about if you really want to change the
world just be obnoxious enough that's
seen in a few times here at Yale but
that's not it either Jesus is taking
this incredible story and he's turning
it all around because you notice it's a
story of a widow and a judge it's not
just a story about somebody asking for
what they want and getting it it's a
story about the least powerful person in
society and the most powerful person in
society and he's contrasting them and
he's asking us partly where am I in this
story I want to think I'm the widow
right I'm faithful I'm persistent I'm
someone who knows what I want and is
humble about it and goes to God and asks
but what the parable is saying is I'm
the judge I'm the person who wants to
say that it can't be done that it's too
complicated that we can't fix things
it's exactly what our whole society is
telling us every day just watch the news
one day it's all about disempowering you
and telling you it's too complicated to
solve we'll have four experts are
usually just two with completely
opposite points of view telling you why
this is right and that is wrong and
leaving you in absolute paralysis that's
the message our society wants to give it
wants us to be the judge to say I'm
sorry I can't help it's too complicated
father John Shea writes about this
parable and what he said just took my
breath away he said this parable is not
about justice being given to this Widow
this parable is about the the widow's
prayers being answered with endurance
the answered prayer is the widow's
strength to keep coming back even when
the answer is no and the scary part if
I'm the judge and God's giving this
strength to the widow is that she's just
going to keep coming she's gonna keep
coming at me until I look at my life and
see where the hurdles are that I'm
placing in her path the story ends with
Jesus saying that God will hear the cry
of his chosen ones for justice and I
wonder how do I make myself one of those
chosen ones how do I make that cry my
own when I'm at Yale when I'm in the
most privileged position in the world no
matter how much I have problems yes I
have problems I pray about those
problems a lot but I'm still here and
still in a place where people make up
the rationalizations to say why nothing
can be done this is it this is the place
right yes job is to complicate things to
give complicated answers and to say why
nothing can be done or why you at least
need to study another 20 years before
you can get to the answer Jesus seems to
be wanting to say you need to get down
there with
widow that's the only solution for
someone who is in a privileged place who
is the judge is to bracket for a moment
what we know about how globalization and
financial flows and all the things we
know about politics bracket them for a
moment and go to that place with that
Widow and sit with her understand her
experience not to make you a bleeding
heart liberal as bleeding heart liberals
usually talk a lot but don't do anything
but to get to that place where you
actually understand her and sympathize
with her and see the connections between
where she is where you are the missing
link I think is that 12 year olds
empathy that doesn't see someone who
looks different or who lives halfway
across the world or someone who seemed
strange as in another category go with a
12 year old to the green on a bad day go
with a 12 year old on trip to Nicaragua
they don't understand how complicated it
is they just see it and they say these
are people why are they being treated
this way
Jesus is stupid and stubborn about this
he won't listen to reason like the ghost
of Christmas yet to come and the
Christmas Carol he just stands there
pointing his finger at the bleeding man
in the ditch beside the Jericho Road and
he says even a Samaritan can show
compassion for a suffering stranger what
about you what would it mean for me to
give that cry for justice it would mean
that I and all my privileges would need
to feel the injustice of them so much
that not only would I feel the pain of
those who suffer for no reason but I
would feel that much more the pain
because I am someone who has everything
for no good reason it would mean that we
need to go out under the Yale campus and
see not only the obvious in justices of
access and salary and inheritance and
background the wicked in their BMWs and
the righteous walking to work at 5am but
I would also have to see the deeper in
justices every day the faceless
thousands or millions who should be at
Yale as much as I am if not more so but
didn't get the breaks I did I would have
to see the people who work in the
chicken processing plant who made my
lunch I would have to see the people in
the sweatshops in Taiwan who made my
clothes I would have to see the people
getting shot and starving and driven
from their homes for no reason around
the world and I would have to see them
all see them all through God's eyes as
god's beloved children my brothers and
my sisters not in the pious sense but in
the literal sense my brothers and my
sisters and then perhaps I could make
that cry this is not to say that even we
privilege for you here don't have our
own individual struggles in life but it
is to say that the kingdom of God is not
about me and God it's about us and God
an ever-widening inclusive circle that
connects me to the suffering of the
world not that I should be destroyed by
it or defeated by it but so
I could feel those connections and feel
finally I can let go of that hurt inside
me that I've been burying for so long
that hurt when I see the injustice of
the world and say it's too complicated
to fix
and the story Jesus is saying to us let
me enlarge your love beyond just what's
in your site so that we might begin to
understand God's love is not just about
me and my family but about everyone
Jesus is saying help me help you out of
your secure and protected life help me
help you understand the cross which was
for all people all people help me help
you treat that hurt that you buried so
deep inside and feel compassion not in
that elite liberal sense but the
compassion of companionship that I am
beside the suffering on their walk it
can happen amen
you